welcome to this video bits off coin ok
let's do jam it again good old Bogle
Bishop g5 that's a very rare move Queen
85 is considered to be okay can also
start with this other people i doing it
I just up and gives up a big Center
person to pony up in no time and it's
not a theoretical line or something it's
just just not any good ok it's develop a
little bit and 65mm night before is not
winning already right no mmm so I'm not
supposed to take it on can I do
something more ambitious she ate me
I'm looking a little bit more difficult
for him to develop night your five is
interesting here still looks you want
sorry my voice is a little bit of yeah
let's do it bit unsure if this is good
or not so i can check him now
93 but it's not clear
I think that this place this move is
somewhat impersonating me of course it
is totally ignored taking on v6 was
interesting so let's see take here
very very weird position but interesting
screen takes 34 now is a threat Andrew
k2 of course so yeah probably i don't
have anything better than this which is
not bad but um still there may be good
for h4 h5 i mean i don't really need to
cover b6 can try to get a score up be
five
it's a bit annoying hmm
h4 would be five Quincy three or
something yeah I'm down on the clock of
course because he was a dashing our
those typically instant moves the whole
time so he I just wrote me too maybe
it's really not helping a lot yeah maybe
in trade one look I don't know
what would a 70 that's maybe the idea
one minute were the three minutes that
wasn't good time management do I have
some kind of idea IM time working g five
maybe four look at five or something
maybe I wants to do this on and just
play on time girl I don't know doesn't
want to play on time maybe I can try to
play a little bit against see for
winning that poem but it's of course a
drawn before I cannot play i can check
him though check i can check in and have
form yeah that is it is good it's good
check check
this is strong this pawn
zoosk one check check check mate who guy
was a bit a bit risky to decline that
wrong but yeah I mean okay from the
position is just it's just probably a
draw but i can i can look at the sea for
porn and the way he played it I was
small winning their porn yeah bro gauge
for still a draw but this is losing can
they just lost I wonder if I may be
probably could have done something
better in the opening I really find that
amazing that they spent seven seconds to
get a chance on that it's just really
wide I mean I can just play keep get
that back yeah I wanted to play it a
little bit too fancy maybe with Luke g8
and stuff trip here yeah maybe I should
just keep that porn I mean I was just
trying to be active and I overlooked
loopy fire that design and that I DM and
he is just equal
I think oops what did the engine just
say rook 86 and white is winning oops
oops that would have been very cool
shower I did I cannot cover that oopsla
ha yeah very nice instead this summer
here you offered that wrong yeah it's a
fighting game what can you do thanks for
watching